I can tell you exactly what happened at Friendster.
It was bad management.
It wasn't platform shift.
It was a bad management team that couldn't keep their servers running.
They couldn't maintain simple things like the integrity of their database.
People's messages were getting corrupted.
The log in times, the load times for every page were going up...
...and that created an opening in the marketplace where Myspace was able to enter.
Myspace never would have existed if Friendster had been a properly managed company.
And I was close to that because most of my friends are investors.
I was adviser to the CEO.
We were all screaming "the sky is falling" and nobody was doing anything about it.
That's a classic case of where a company just blew it.
And Myspace is another case where a company just blew it.
Facebook had no chance to win.
We should not have won the market.
The network effects at Myspace were so powerful.
The only reason we won was because of the gross incompetence of Myspace systematically...
...over a period of many years.
Did I just say that publicly?